when you said that ufos
are just some small part of a larger
yeah project what did you meant
phenomena what do you mean i like to say
to the phenomenon i believe
from well the evidence shows me that
ufos is a very small
aspect of a much larger phenomenon okay
so what i mean by that is that
ufos appear to be part of a larger
phenomenon meaning
ufos are are kind of an auxiliary
uh implication of a much larger reality
so this idea that what we're seeing are
machines from other planets i i'm
unconvinced what we may be seeing
is an alternate reality you know maybe
it is something closer to
you know dimensional travel there seems
to be
another version of reality that is
occurring
and that somehow once in a while they
they
perfray and they pop through into our
reality
and this is not just from a cursory look
at the ufo phenomenon that this is from
talking with
thousands of close encounter
eyewitnesses
who tell me that this is something
bigger than just
flying machines to give you an example
at skinwalker ranch
the report is that a piece of the sky
opened up like a
tear and out of this terror came
beings you know uh came craft
so so ufos is a symptom it's part of
this
alternate reality the phenomenon as i
call it
but it's it's not just about ufos ufos
represent
this phenomenon